[Música]
[Aplausos]
muy buenas no quería quedarme aquí sin
un beso de cristina pero se ha fugado es
un honor para nosotros estar aquí
cantando algo que como bien decía
cristina me ha acompañado tantos años y
esto a ella le recuerda la infancia a mí
casi el útero y esto es un regalo para
ella para ti y para todas nosotras así
disfrutar este es un tema es una samba
al principio es 'alfonsina y el mar'
no
[Música]
ah
por la blanda
[Música]
que no
no
[Música]
su pequeña huella
el demás
un sendero solo de pena y silencio llegó
hasta el agua profundo
un sendero solo de perder
dudas ciego
[Música]
dios qué angustia
de aquí
año
[Música]
que dolores viejos
cayó tu voz
[Música]
para recordarte arrollada en el campo de
las caracolas marinas
la canción que canta en el fondo
más
na
y nada
[Música]
tanto soledad que poemas nuevos fuiste a
buscar una voz antigua de viento y de
sal
se requiere entrenar
qué es esto
este mal
se halla como en sueños dormida
alfonsina vestida de mar
ah
[Música]
5 serenidad
d
[Música]
por caminos de algas
y de llorar
[Música]
y fosforescentes caballos marinos harán
una ronda a tu lado
y los habitantes de nada
para jugar
pronto a tu lado
bajo de la
pero cómo
[Música]
déjame que duerma
no veis
ah
[Música]
y si amáis no le digas nunca que esto ya
dijo
y 2
[Música]
no le di
que mi hijo
así
soledad que no ve más nuevos
a buscar una voz antigua del viento y de
sal
qué era esto
víctimas
se halla como en sus niños
dormida
con senna vestida
d
[Música]
[Risas]
muchas gracias
y
hay una canción que también recoge
la necesidad de ofrecernos a través de
la música esto lo escribió un mago
argentino llamado fito páez
se llama yo vengo a ofrecer mi corazón y
es en el fondo lo que esta noche creo
que todos todas venimos a hacer
ofrecernos cada uno a través de lo que
sabe de lo que conoce a través de la
música en nosotros muchas gracias
[Música]
quién dijo que todo esto
yo ofrecer mi corazón
tanta sangre que se llevó el río
dios ofrecer mi corazón
no será tan fácil
ya sé qué pasa
dice nada
sensible
cómodo
estaba como abrir el pecho
y sacar en la
e
una cuchilla
de amor
y una de los pobres siempre abierta
yo crecer mi corazón
con un documento inalterable yo podré
ser mi
el corazón y uniré las puntas
de un mismo lazo
tranquila
mira
espacio quedará todo
es algo algo que me alivia
y poco más
[Música]
cuando no haya nadie cerco lejos
yo vengo a ofrecer mi corazón
[Música]
cuando los satélites marcan
y yo vengo a ofrecer mi corazón
y hablo de países libre esperanzas
bueno
nada
de cambiar
está nuestra casa
ah
que también las orcas
no más
[Música]
quien dijo que todo está perdido
yo
y todas vengo a ofrecer
me
corazón
[Música]
i
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]